hello everyone and welcome to one of the
craziest games that was played in the
2018 batumi Chess Olympiad for now it's
played between even charge of Croatia
and Parham axle of Iran at the
definitely an important match up and you
all know how Max Weber became the Junior
World Championship not so long ago we've
shown a couple of games he played they
were absolutely stunning he won the
entire world the Junior Championship
which nine and a half points or 10 and a
half points out of 11th yeah I believe
with an amazing amazing rating
performance here he faces even Charlie
she went cherish was also a junior world
champion himself here is a nice photo of
him and Valentina go ljubinko some 10
years ago this was in 2008 when he also
won the World Junior Championships so
basically this is a game between two two
world champions and it's really really
an interesting line of the reuleaux PES
and it features so many so many tricky
tricky maneuvers and and puzzles to
solve but you'll see what I mean
best dive straight into it so like we
said it's a rule Opus even opens with a
4s here is an e4 player and he's a very
very aggressive player at that e5 Knight
to f3 Knight to c6 and Bishop to b5 a6
we have more fees defense to the real
Opus Bishop to a 409 to f6 we have
castles and b5 so nothing out of the
ordinary here Bishop to b3 we have
Bishop to c5 c3 g6 and the d4 and here
it's very interesting it's a it's a well
known line that was one of the more
famous games is Fabiano Caruana versus
magnus cross and it was played in 2017
in Isle of Man chess festival were
Caruana lost against Carlsen but also he
won against Wayne Jones in the same line
so a very interesting we're gonna
mention that in a bit but it's also very
interesting to mention that so far
Perham actual boom lost only one game in
this tournament in the batumi chess
Olympia 2018 against the Grandmaster
victrolas michka
and even cherish lost only one game to
Dingley rain and
also it's very interesting that shark
drew his game in Round seven against
Fabiana Caruana whereas Parham hawks
withdrew his game against ding Liron two
runs prior to this game so the only
player who beat even Charlie in the
Olympiad so I thought you'd be
interested in that
okay now we have Bishop back to be six
and a four
rook to b8 and here comes a five a five
is a well-known maneuver we already
mentioned Khurana did played against
Carson in 2017 Isle of Man chess
festival and here comes the bishop 287
you don't want to capture the pond it's
it's a known trap if you capture it with
the bishop then you get D captures on e5
pawn captures and now Queen captures on
d8 you can't capture with the night
because the knight has to keep
protecting the bishop and after capture
with the king to d5 a very simple move
simply attacking the defender of the
bishop and you can just move the knight
because it's defending the bishop and it
doesn't really matter if you defended
the night and you can't move the bishop
because nothing is protecting the night
either
so after Knight captures pawn captures
you will either win a knight or a bishop
here on the other hand if you capture
with the knight Knight captures then
rook captures on a5 is the idea I very
nice exchange sacrifice after Bishop
captures now comes D captures on e5 you
can't capture here again since you'll
get Queen captures King characters and
now Knight captures on e5 and this will
be sufficient compensation for the
exchange and on the other hand if you
instead after Bishop captures on a5 pawn
captures pawn captures well you won't
play pawn captures but rather you will
play Knight captures any four then comes
Queen to d5 attacking the knight and
also threatening Queen captures on f7
checkmate so after Bishop to e6 you
don't lose a piece yet but after Queen
captures Bishop captures you will get
nice to d4 and now your better piece
under attack if you want to save the
bishop you will get nice to see six
women attack on the rook and the Queen
so white will definitely be better here
so like we said a well-known trap Bishop
to a7 played instantly by Paramore Zulu
and both even in Parma
spending very little time a couple of
seconds per move here so both of them
very well prepared we have h3 castles so
far this game is completely copying the
game
Korona versus Carlson from the Isle of
Man festival in 2017 Bishop to e3 we
have looked back to 8/9 to d2 and now h6
rook to e1 we have looked to e8 and here
we have Queen to c2 this is a new move
by charge
carvanha played the g4 against Carson
and like we said he lost that game so a
charge tries a different idea I'm not
sure if he he was following the game on
purpose but most likely I mean it's a
game between cost and Caruana most
likely both of them knew of this game so
Queen to c2 here he spent a bit more
time on this move and it captures on d4
ok Knight captures Knight captures C
chapters on d4 and now comes c5 why does
have a very nice Center so black of
course it wants to attack it and here a
5 by shot each a shortage spent very
little on this move I think some two and
a half minutes and here Mac Zulu had to
think for the first time and it's a very
dangerous position one thing you have to
notice is that the bishop is attacking
the f7 pawn not only that it's spinning
it so moves like Queen to g6 are
definitely a possibility
one such line we could check out this is
a pawn capture son d4 and now Bishop
captures an h6 with to this attack you
don't want to capture and allow Queen g6
to come with check but whatever you play
rook captures on e5 Queen g6 is coming
now threatening checkmate and also
capturing on f7 so Queen has to block
both threats Queen to f8 and now rook
captures on e5 d captures on e5 and now
rook to c1 the rook is coming to c7 it
would be a very dangerous position to
play with black so Mac Zulu doesn't
spend too much on this position some
four minutes I believe and he finds the
best idea you have to block this bishops
path to f7 so c4 e captures on f6
would have seek after son b3 and then
out comes the Queen to c6 a nice move by
the Queen attack
the rockin a8 and also attacking the
pawn on d6 so while mock Zulu has to do
something with the rocket Bishop to f4
is coming with a double attack against
this week d6 pawn look to be it was
played now comes at Bishop to f4 with a
double attack
and here comes rook captures on e1 rook
captures any one and now Bishop the b7
with an attack on the Queen Queen
captures on d6 grabbing a pawn and now
comes g5 a very nice idea but it it
doesn't work if you capture the Queen
Queen captures then Bishop captures
attacks the rook if you move the rook
for example if rook to d8
attacking the bishop then you get rook
to Bishop to c7 this is a very nice trap
and now you cannot capture the pawn this
is the problem if you capture the pawn
then you get to rook check King moves
and now pawn captures here threatening
the head the Queen and checkmate and if
you capture with the king then comes
Bishop to e5 check this wins the rook
the exchange and thus the game so after
this Queen to d6
Mac subbu doesn't go for the Queen
rather g5 is played making some
additional room for the King and also
attacking the bishop here and here while
you do have a lot of options there is
only one best move and even charge
indeed place it so feel free to pause
the video here and try to find the move
a charge played the only move that
allows the white to push for for the win
I'll give you a couple of seconds to
decide what do we want to do it for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are really an
amazing attacker because it's not an
easy move to find and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show
rook to e7 is the idea why is it such a
powerful move well mainly because the
bishops are here this Bishop is on b7 it
cannot move because then da some Bishop
is unguarded and on the other hand the
a7 Bishop has to stay there to keep an
eye on the rook as you'll see in a
couple of lines and what do you do here
if you capture the Queen now then of
course the bunch of characters here
attacks the rook and you can't move the
rook because the bishop will be a week
even rook to d8 with an attack on black
a white
dark square Bishop doesn't work because
of rook captures rook captures rook
captures and now after rook captures on
d4 simply move the knight there are no
threats here the King has a very nice
escape square so all is well here now on
the other hand after rook to e7 if you
don't capture the Queen if you play
something like Queen to f8 you don't
want to play something then Bishop to e5
is very strong
rook to d8 attacking the Queen then
comes Queen to c7 and again you see that
it's it's very hard to hold this with
black both of the bishops are under
attack and after something like Bishop
captures on d4 you can even go for a
move like rook captures on f7 as the
King cannot capture of course and if the
Queen captures then Queen captures on d8
if Bert captures on f2 trying to get the
King out the capture on d2 with check
simply King to f1 and now after Queen
captures Queen captures here Queen to f8
now comes Queen capture skin captures
and after King CalPERS on f2 white would
be a puppy upper piece and winning the
game so these are only only two of the
lines that are a very popular for white
but mcdougal goes for a different one he
plays GTA afters on f4 he grabs a piece
but now he must face the consequences
Queen captures on f4 a very nice move by
shark that threatens Queen to h6 with
some nasty chart mating ideas here if
you play something like Queen to f8
guarding the pawn then d5 would be very
nice simply blocking this this strong
Bishop and again you it will be it will
be very hard to hold this with black but
Queen to defy was played here by Parham
hawk Sulu and this is a terrible blunder
that losses on spot so feel free to
pause the video here and try to find the
refutation against this Queen to d5 idea
as it does threaten checkmate I'll give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
follower of my other social media
because I've already mentioned this
there and for those who just want to
enjoy the show
the idea is rook captures on b7 removing
the threat of
checkmate and now whatever you do if
Queen captor son be seven simply Queen
captures here and now there's no move
that prevents Queen Queen to g7
checkmate so it's all over for black and
on the other hand if you decide to
capture with the rook it doesn't really
change anything Queen captures h6 and I
and again there's no move that prevents
Queen to g7 checkmate black can stall a
little but doesn't really change
anything and lastly but not leastly
Queen to g5 simply blocking any threats
doesn't really work because now rook
captures unbe eight with Czech Bishop
captures and Queen captures with check
King moves and now comes 94 attacks the
Queen and after Queen checks King H -
there is no Queen to a4 check or
anything not that it would matter but
you know Queen is covering f4 so no
tricks are even possible here so this
would have won the game on spot after
Queen to d5 but even goes for a
different move
he plays rook to a knife to e4 and this
is what I mean by the title of this
video because I wasn't watching the live
coverage from the start I started right
about somewhere around here right I saw
the engine bar going crazy and I was
like oh very nice I mean it's a victory
against such a strong opponent like
partner Mach Zulu I think it even allows
even charge to break
20700 for the first time I believe it's
for the first time I don't think he was
ever over 20 2700 so I was very
impressed by this and then when I saw he
didn't go for it I was like was it such
a hard move to find I have no idea
because I already saw the engine
evaluation when you see the engine
evaluation you immediately know that
there's a punch line to the position so
it's easier to solve it that's why when
someone asks me in the comments why
don't I add the engine bar evaluation
it's because it really kills the magic
and you have to enjoy the position and
analyze it yourself but it's not the
only time it happens in this game 994
okay you block checkmate also the knight
is covering g5 so the Queen cannot come
to g5 but it does allow Queen to h5 the
only move that Parham can use to
actually defend
so what do you do here even played Queen
to g3t 5 was also an idea but ok Queen
Tajiri check we have Queen to g6 and
Queen captures on g6 with check
we have pawn captures and now comes
Knight to d6 so shark is still down down
a piece but he has a very strong attack
and it seems like everything is going
his way
Mach Sulu goes for the for King to f8 if
rook to f8 this was also possible then
you get f7 check King goes back and then
after rook attacks King can simply
defend and now you would be forced to
capture on b7 and enter enter this
endgame but max Lulu goes for a
different line he goes king to f8 which
is slightly a slightly worse than then
the line we've already shown now even
has a very strong move that he is able
to find its rook to h7 he spent a lot of
time on this move I think around 20
minutes and now it's very hard well
impossible to defend for black rook to
h8 is that is the threat this would be
checkmate as the knight and pawn or
covering all of these squares so you
have to prevent this King to g8 was
played and this is the crit the most
critical moment in the game
I feel free to pause the video here and
find the winning move for white I'll
give you a couple of seconds to decide
what we want to do it or not for those
of you who were able to do it
congratulations once again you are an
excellent follower of my other social
media because I've also already posted
this the move that wins here is believe
it or not f7 if you found the rook to g7
this is also winning because whatever
black plays you can also force this same
position if you play f7 all over again
but f7 is winning because now whatever
black plays well let's say we capture
the rook then comes nice to e8 simply
blocking the rooks coverage of the f8
square and the pawn is covering the g8
and the knight is covering g7 so the
King cannot approach the pond next move
white is getting a queen so this seems
again it seems very simple and after f7
check if you move the king
then comes a route to h8 check King
moves doesn't really matter if the King
moves to g7 or to e7 regardless of where
black moves in the White's next move is
rook to e8 and now you have to allow the
Queen either you will move the king and
then white gets a queen or you will
capture here and then after Queen comes
into the game you can capture here but
then the bishops are once again very
weak
if King blocks d5 you have to move and
now it's all over
so again I was very unimpressed that I
actually knew that there is a win here
because of the damn engine evaluation
but even missed this even did not play
f7 even played a rook to g7 check and I
was like I'm never again watching a live
coverage where there is an engine
evaluation because it really stresses
you out King to f8 was played f king to
a trait of K if King tha then after
seven will be checkmate so of course max
Lulu goes for King to f8 and now comes
route back to f7 check King to g8 and
again we have a position where rook to
g7 is winning because then charge can go
for the same line and repeat with with
rook to h7 but here he actually goes
rook to d7 he doesn't find this
continuation and now he has to go into
an endgame Bishop captures on d4 was
played and now comes f7 with check but
now it's different King to f8 blocks and
now comes Knight captures on b7 rook
captures rook captures and now Bishop
captures on b2 so strategy is up the
exchange but black has a very dangerous
past b3 pawn rook to c7 explain you have
to make it in time with the rook to stop
the pawn bishop to DeForest plate and
down rook to c1 as B 2 is coming so you
have to be ready to play rook to be 1
here we have King captures on f7 a b2
was possible but you can play it
afterwards the like it was played in the
game King to f1 charge tries to bring
the King over as it's the endgame you do
have to play with your King King to e6
here we have king to e2 and King to d5
here time
troll was reached this is more 40 by
both players and the mock Sulu I believe
he had like 30 seconds before reaching
tank patrol so he was really struggling
to defend a very difficult position King
to D 3 and now comes the b2 rook rook to
d1 you have to keep an eye on the b1
square and here Bishop captures on f2
again now that finally tank control was
reached and Mac Zulu had the plenty of
time he makes an inaccuracy that allows
even to push for for something more it's
you you shouldn't allow the King to to
reach the c3 square but even if you
don't if you play something like g5 then
you will miss your chance to capture
here so it's hard to say everything
black is in a very tough situation
I bought ok after rook to d1 Bishop
captures was played on now King to c3 of
course a shortage wants to eliminate the
past pawn King King to c5 and now comes
King captures on b2 we have h5 and now
comes came to b3
we have Bishop to h4 now comes rook to
c1 check King moves and rook to c8 you
have to grab start grabbing these pawns
as they are all on light squares so
there will be easy targets brush up to
e1 going after the a5 pawn and now rook
to e8 in the strongest idea but so
captures rook captures here with an
attack on the bishop the bishop moves
and now comes Luke captures and be sick
on g6 h4 trying to cement that pawn on a
dark square but it doesn't help rook to
g5 check came to e4 and now rook
captures on b5 King to e3 and now King
to c4 now max would lose idea is if he
can grab those pawns then perhaps he
could draw this game King to f2 but now
comes a rook to be to check King moves
and now comes King to King to d3 Bishop
to f2 now the king is ready to grab the
pawn but it doesn't matter shot him to
place King to e4 we have king capture
son g2 and now comes King to f5 and this
was a a very nice continuation as now
you have to choose whether you whether
you want to protect keep protecting your
bishop and then rook to b3 is coming or
you wanna capture the last bond and
allow rook captures an f2 to be played
both of it both of it is winning for
white so max will tried king chapters on
h3 but it doesn't help him rook captures
on f2 was played came to g3 and now rook
to be two he starts pushing his past
pawn we have h3 rook to b3 check King to
g2 King to g4 and here at h2 rook to be
to check King to g1 and here Charlotte
simply jump to g3 this is why most
likely WiMAX will go tried this
variation instead of trying to save the
bishop because now he is able to promote
his pawn but it doesn't matter as it was
in this position and move 63 even the
second time in control was reached that
world junior champion Parham hawk Sulu
resigned in the game he resigned because
of course if you grab the Queen then you
get rook to be one and this will be
checkmate and on the other hand if you
go for a different more exciting line
which is grabbing the night this comes
with check so checkmate is prevented for
the time being but doesn't really matter
if you try something like King to f3
then comes King to f1 and now you will
again be checkmate it on the other hand
if after King to f3 you don't move the
King you move the knight you don't
really have a lot of options if you move
the knight here you will simply lose it
and get checkmated afterwards and if you
try nice to f2 again that doesn't really
help you simply check you have to move
the King and now King captures King h3
and now a very easy checkmating sequence
rook to h4 so after King to g3 Parham ox
will decided to resign the game and very
very difficult difficult to win for the
the strongest creation chess player even
charge so I mean it's really first that
whole rook captures on b7 idea then f7
would check idea it's really are you
think that it's it's an easy easy align
because you see the engine evaluation
and it screams like yes white is winning
but it's like even so Colo said he
actually meant
[Music]
regarding the Caruana versus mamedyarov
game that it's easy to tweet when your
engine does all the work and he's
definitely right here because he was
reading some of the tweets and they were
like oh yeah it's winning it's winning
and he was like where's the win and he's
a very strong grandmaster soul you know
yeah better better enjoyed chess without
an engine evaluation you first do it
yourself and then only afterwards you
know check with an engine if you must
so yeah that's the game a very nice game
by even charge and I do have to mention
here is a photo from the live feed you
see Max Weber is really having a hard
time in this end game but he's not he's
not like this because of the terrible
position his he's in but rather I saw
him use a handkerchief throughout the
entire game so I think he here has a
cold or something and it's really it's
really difficult to play a classical
game that lasts for five or six hours
when you're not physically at full
health but you know such as chest you
will you will not always be at full
health so yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it we're gonna cover some of
the other games from round 8 and we're
gonna check out the results afterwards
as some of the games were still being
played but this was definitely a very
important win for Croatia against Iran I
don't know how it ended as some one game
was still being played I would like to
thank Stephen green James urado Victor
Mario and Sinuessa Krish Christian
Gonzalez Gonzalez castelia and Alexandra
pep run for a contribution to my channel
thank you what I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
I'll see you soon
with hopefully with another interesting
video thank you all and I'll see you
soon